JIMMY TRAN:
Container-optimized OS
is an operating system image
for your Compute Engine VMs
that is optimized for
running Docker containers
and is Google's
recommended operating
system for running containers
on Google Cloud Platform.
On this episode of
Google Cloud LABS,
we'll review what you'll
learn in this quick lab, where
you will create a
container-optimized instance
using the Cloud
Console and a CLI.
Now, remember, you do not need
a Google Cloud Platform account
or project to do this lab.
An account, project,
and associated resources
are provided to you.
Now let's get to it.
During the lab, you will
learn to create a VM
with the container-optimized
OS and a Docker container
using a CLI.
You'll also learn to create a
firewall rule to allow access,
and can reach the
default Nginx page using
the external IP of the VM.
At the end of this
lab, you'll be
able to create a
Compute Engine instance
with the container-optimized
OS and a Docker
container of your choice
using the GCP Console
and a command-line interface.
Since it comes with all
container-related dependencies
pre-installed,
Container-Optimized OS
allows your cluster to quickly
scale up or down in response
to traffic or workload
changes, optimizing your spend
and improving your reliability.
Container-Optimized OS
powers many GCP services,
such as Kubernetes
engines and Cloud SQL,
making it Google's
go-to solution
for container workloads.
Qwiklabs is an online,
hands-on lab library
with more than 150 labs on
every cloud topic from intro
to expert level.
Each lab helps you learn a
new skill in about 30 minutes
using Google Cloud.
When you're ready, use this
link to take the lab we just
went through today.
And when you're ready
to sign up for GCP,
use this link to apply a
$300 credit to your account.
We want to hear from you.
Every week we'll answer a
question from our viewers.
So let us know what's on your
mind in the comments below.
[ELEVATOR MUSIC PLAYING]